bu içinde dünyamızın da olduğu güneş
sisteminde sekiz tane gezegen var
biliyorsunuz 9 ile hatırlıyorsanız o
pilotu artık gezegenden sayılmıyor güneş
sisteminin dışında olupda bu güne kadar
tespit edebildikleri mizde 4000'den
fazla hiç merak ettiniz mi acaba dünya
dışındaki bu gezegenlerden birinde de
hayat olma ihtimali var mı diye
ya ben bir kere bile etmedim neden
anlatayım şimdi ankara'dayız ve bu
dünyaya bakmaya çok alışık olduğumuz bir
açı ben size dünyayı başka bir açıdan
göstermek istiyorum
bu çevirip de böyle baktığımız zaman
ankara tabi yok artık ama hemen hemen
başka hiç karada yok yok çünkü bizim
gezegenimizin yüze yetmişinden fazlası
deniz ama bu denizlerimizin sadece yüzde
beşinin içinden ne olduğundan haberdar
mısın mesela en derin noktanın yaklaşık
11 kilometre olduğunu biliyoruz çünkü
1875'te ölçüsüz ama o noktaya içinde
insan olan bir denizaltıyla ulaşmamız
1960 zaten 1969'da ay'a gitmişiz yani
denebilir ki okyanusun dibine gitmek
bekaya gitmek kadar zormuş iş okyanusun
içine bakmak daha hala 100'de 95'i ne
bakamadığımız a göre demek ki ondan da
zor
o çünkü karanlık denizin üzerinde kırıl
pırıl parlayan güneş ışığı suya girdiği
zaman en iyi şartlar altında yaklaşık
100-150 metre kadar derine ulaşabiliyor
ondan sonra tamamen yok oluyor tabi ışık
da bizim hayatımızın merkezinde olan
görme duyumuzu çalıştırdığı için ışığın
olmaması denizin içinde ne var ne yok
keşf edebilmemiz in önündeki en büyük
engellerden birisi 1977 yılında
galapagos adaları yakınında denizin ta
iki buçuk kilometre derininde çok önemli
bir keşif yapıldı ışığın zerresi olmadan
da hayat olabileceğini ilk defa
öğrenmemize sebep olan içinden kaynar
sular fışkıran su altı bacıları ve
bunların etrafında hayatından gayet
memnun yaşayan hayvanlar keşfedildi
ve buradaki keşfin önemli kısmı
bacaların bulunması değil o tahmin
ediliyordu ama bacaların etrafında hayat
olabilmesi ydi çünkü o güne kadar biz
ışık yoksa hayatta olamaz diye denizin
karanlık kısmında sadece başka
hayvanların ölüsüyle beslenebilen ufacık
hayvanlar yaşar zannediyorduk yani sığ
sularda ışık olan sularda da mikroskobik
bitkiler fotosentez yapacak küçük
hayvanlar o bitkiler yiyecek daha büyük
hayvanlar o küçük hayvanları yiyecek
sonra mesela devasa bir balina da ölüp
dibe çöktüğü zaman aşağıda karanlıkta
yaşayan garibanlar da bir şey ye bilmiş
olacaklar çay ki bu bacaların etrafında
yaşayan hayvanlar barışık'a veya
fotosentez yapan başka hiçbir hayvana
muhtaç olmadan kendi besinlerini
kimyasal enerjiyi dönüştü
bu sürede biliyorlardı yani kemosentez
yaparak bu hiç beklenmeyen bir şeydir
bilim dünyası şoke oldu biz de ders
kitaplarına hayat kavramını hayatı
nerede ve nasıl oluşabileceğini yeni
baştan yazdık daha 1977 o kadar eski bir
tarih değil 1977'de kendi
gezegenimizdeki hayatla ilgili bu kadar
temel bir bilgiye sahip değil inanın
bugün de aynı durumdayız mesela mars'ın
yüzeyinin haritasını 1996'da çıkartmış
hız ama hala kendi denizlerimizin içinde
ne var ne yok haberimiz yok işte ben
bugün size denizin dibindeki karanlığın
sebebini anlatmak istiyorum ne oluyor da
güneş ışığı suya girdiği zaman yok
oluyor
sen neden bizim sualtında çektiğimiz
fotoğraflar hep mavi ve karanlık çıkıyor
aslında sualtında çektiğiniz her
fotoğraf iki ayrı fotoğrafın üst üste
eklenmesinden oluşuyor bu iki ayrı
fotoğrafı oluşturan mekanizmaya da sis
mekanizması ve sokak lambası mekanizması
diyelim mesela ankara'da muhabiri
görünmez kılacak kadar yoğun olan siz
normal bir durum değil zaten bu mavide
kameradan bir buçuk en fazla iki metre
mesafede normal şartlar altında bizi
yüzünün makyajını kıyafetini detaylarını
görebiliyoruz hatta genellikle arkasında
heyecanlı bir olay oluyor onuda
rahatlıkla seyrede biliyoruz
bu ama siz detayları yok ediyor şu
karada anormal bir durum olan yoğun sis
suyun altında her gün var yani normal
bunun sebebi de suyun içinde asılı duran
mikroskobik parçacıkların havada asılı
duran mikroskobik parçacıklardan çok
daha büyük olması ve abuk sabuk
şekillerinin olması yani ışık bu
parçalara çarptığı zaman tüm enerjisiyle
her yöne doğru saçılıyor saçıldığı
yönlerde başka büyük ve çirkin parçalara
çarpıp tekrar tekrar saçılıyor böyle
olunca da çok kısa bir mesafe içinde
metrelerle ifade ettiğimiz mesafe
içerisinde yoğun sis oluşuyor bunu
havada olması için de bizim havaya
mesela hava kirliliği yolunda büyük
parçalar eklemiş olmamız veya doğal
şartlardan büyük parçaları nasıl duruyor
olması gerekiyor yani birinci mekanizma
sual
bu taraflarını etkileyen kötü
çıkmalarına sebep olan birinci mekanizma
hepimizin bildiği sis ikincisi de sokak
lambası mekanizması biliyorsunuz gece
sokakları aydınlatan sodyum buharlı
lambalar sarı ışık verir siz bu lambanın
altına renginin beyaz olduğunu
bildiğiniz arabanızı park edip
fotoğrafını çekerseniz arabanın
fotoğrafta sarı çıkar bunun sebebi de
bizim renk dediğimiz göreceli kavramın
tamamen etrafı aydınlatan ışığın rengine
bağlı olması arada ışığın rengi beyaz
içinde de yok kuşağın her rengi var ama
ışık havadan suya geçip ilerlemeye
başladığı zaman bir o parçalara çarptığı
zaman renklerinin bir tanesi hariç
hepsini kaybediyor yani diyebiliriz ki
suyun içine rengi mavi olan bir sokak
lambası
devam ediyor şimdi mavi ışık altında her
şey mavi görünüyor kontrast azalıyor
renklerin birbirinden ayırt edilebilmesi
imkansız hale geliyor yani bir nevi bu
mavi ışık bakanı renk körü yapıyor bu da
ikinci mekanizma
bir sokak lambası mekanizmas şimdi biz
bu iki mekanizmayı ve arkasındaki fiziği
ta 1930'lardan beri biliyoruz
1990'lardan 1'de yani dijital kameralar
ve sualtı kılıfları piyasaya çıktığından
1'de dünyanın her yerinde her gün
bilimsel amaçlı binlerce fotoğraf
çekiyoruz çekiyoruz ama çektiğimiz hızda
bu fotoğrafları işleyip
kullanabileceğimiz bir iyi
dönüştüremiyorum zor otomatik yazılımlar
bilgisayarla görme ve öğrenme
algoritmaları bu anlattığım sis ve sokak
lambası mekanizmaları yüzünden tutarlı
bir şekilde çalışmıyor çünkü aramaya
şartlandırılması kları detayları sualtı
fotoğraflarında bulamıyorlar
ve bu yüzden de biz deniz bilimlerinde
yapay zeka teknolojilerinden doğru
dürüst yararlanamıyoruz ama merak
ediyorsunuz biliyorum tabii ki marsa
indirdiğimiz robotlar yapay zekayı hem
de gerçek zamanlı kullanan kameralara
sahip olduğu için nereden taş toprak
örneği alacaklarını gerçek zamanlı
olarak otonom olarak karar
verebiliyorlar
bu peki biz bu fiziği 1930'lardan beri
biliyorsak ve 90'lardan biri de
elimizden milyonlarca sualtı fotoğrafı
geçtiyse bu kaybolan renkleri kontrastı
detayları yeri getirme problemini neden
hala çözemedik
ama asla cevabı basit çünkü fiziği bilen
bilim insanları sağ fotoğraflarla
görüntü işleme ile çalışmıyorlar
bu görüntü işlemede uzman bilgisayar
bilimciler bu konuyla ilgili fizik
kurallarını tam bilmiyorlar ve her iki
grup da biyolojik etkenlerden haberdar
değil biyolojiyi görmezden gelirsek
problemi sadece kısmen çözmüş oluyoruz
çünkü doğal su kütlelerinde o mavi sokak
lambası her zaman mavi yanmaz yeşil
olabilir
bu kahverengi olabilir hatta tamamen
doğal sebeplerden pembe bile olabilir
yani bir fizikçi bilgisayar bilimci
biyolog beraber bir bara gitse
bu problemi çözeceğiz şimdi biyolog
demişken 1998'de önemli bir olay oldu
ben üniversite sınavına girdim şimdi
deniz biyoloğu olmak istiyorum tercihler
yapılmadan önceki gece de babam dedi ki
ya sen şimdi denizyolu olursan senin
emeğine saygı gösterecek sana insanca
yaşayabileceği maaşı ödeyecek hangi
fırında çalışacaksın senin kafan fiziğe
basıyor bence sen mühendis ol
seçeneklerin artar ondan sonra helva
istiyorsan dönüp deniz diyorsa okursun
dedi
e tabi bu deniz biyolojisi okunmayacak
demenin kraliçe elizabeth asaletiyle
söylenmiş hali tamam yazdık bütün
mühendisleri puan sırasına göre benim
puanım da altı tercihim olan havacı da
odtü havacılık ve uzay mühendisliği
tuttu havacılığa öyle özel bilgim yoktu
uzaya da hiç bilgim yoktu
yok ama yine de bölümü de arkadaşlarımı
da çok severek okudum şu yaptığım işi
hakkıyla yapmaya çalıştığım için de
birincilikle bitirdim arkasından emayti
den pertekten stanfield en havacılık
bölümlerinden yüksek lisans için kabul
aldım ve gittim bir sürede o uçak
motorlarının termodinamiğe üzerine
çalıştım
var ama hiç heyecan duyamadım ve kendimi
de o işi hayat boyu yaparken göremedim
bu zor bir durum çünkü sizden
beklentiler var size gösterilen yolda
yürü müsünüz sizin için en iyisi olduğu
söylenen her şeyi yapmışsınız ama
geldiğimiz noktada ben burada ne
yapıyorum diyorsunuz
evet tamam bu bana göre değil dedim bir
de iş hayatına bakalım dedim yazılım
alanında danışmanlık yapmaya başladım
epey para kazandım
var ama günde 11.00 12.00 1.00 ofiste
bilgisayar başında çalıştığım için bazı
seneler mevsimlerin değiştiğini bile
kaçırdım yani iş hayatında başarılı
olacağım diye dua ile bağlantısı
kesilmişti ve bu beni eksik bir insan
yaptı
ve o noktada şunu gördüm
evet hop gibi emayti gibi okullarda
okuma şansına ayrıcalığına sahip bir
insanın
bu eğer ben hayatımı bile bile mutsuz
olduğum bir yöne sürersem
bu potansiyelinin en tepesine çıkamazsam
kendime ve topluma da en büyük katkıyı
yapacağım şekilde yaşayamazsam bu benim
kadar şanslı olmayan pırıl pırıl
gençleri haksızlık olmaz mı
ve hatta bir adım da yeri atıp bakarsak
türkiye olmayan bir müslüman ülkede
doğdukları için değil iki mühendislik
arasında tercih yapmak temel eğitim
alabilmeleri veya yalnız sokağa
çıkabilmeleri erkeklerin rızasına bağlı
olan kadınlara haksızlık olmaz mı
çok teşekkür ederim soruları böyle
sorduğumda cevaplar çok netti o zaman
iyice düşündüm ve benim için mutluluk
nedir onun formülü çıkarttı ben denizi
doğayı senede iki hafta tatile
gittiğimde değil hayatımın her gününde
görmek istiyorum
sen hayatımın bana ait olan kısmı işten
eve geldiğimde uyanık alabildiğim o üç
saatle sınırlı olmasını istiyorum ve de
ben her ne işi yapacaksam sabah
kalktığımda heyecanla koşa koşa
gidebilmek istiyorum işte o noktada
üniversiteden ayrılalı seneler olmuştu
hatta çok iyi hatırlıyorum integral
almayı bile unutmuştum şu sıfırdan
başlamayı göze aldım ve üniversiteye
dönüp deniz bilimlerinde doktoraya
başladım
ya aslında anlattığım şeyler birbirinden
bağlantısız gibi görünüyor mu değil
bu pirinç elizabeth sayesinde odtü'de
çok sağlam bir fizik ve mühendislik
eğitimi aldığım için yazılımla haşır
neşir olduğum birkaç sene geçirdiğim
için ve de gözümü karartıp okula
dönebilecek kadar denize tutku duyduğum
için kenar parçaları bulunmuş ama ortası
30 senedir boş duran yapbozun
ve o birleştirici parçasını koyan bilim
insanı olarak karşınızdayım bugün size
iki dakika 38 saniyede anlattım sis ve
sokak lambası mekanizmalarının sualtı
fotoğrafları etkilerini ve bunu nasıl
hesaplayıp tersine çevirebileceğimiz i
yaklaşık dört sene mi alan üç bilimsel
makale de açıkladım sizi hesaplayıp
fotoğraflardan çıkarttığımız da da kalan
mavi ışığı da beyaza çevirdiğimizde bar
olan ama görmediğimiz renkleri ve
detayları tekrar ortaya çıkartabiliyor
uz ve bunu objektif bir şekilde
tekrarlanabilir bir şekilde otomatik
olarak yapabiliyoruz
var yani deniz bilimlerinde yapay zeka
çağının kapısını açmış oluyoruz
var ama burası yolun sonu değil aslında
sadece başlangıcı çünkü ancak şimdi daha
büyük soruları sormaya başlayabiliriz
benim her gün kafamı kurcalayan bir soru
var bir denizin içinde de renkler var o
arama denizin içindeki ışık bu renkleri
yok ediyor bu o zaman denizin içine
renkler neden var kimse göremeyecek
seneden var denizde ahtapoti bir kalamar
dediğimiz hepsi birbiriyle akraba
kafadan bacaklı çok acayip hayvanlar var
biliyorsunuz
ve bunların çok lezzeti olmanın yanı
sıra bir özelliği daha var yeryüzünde
hiçbir hayvanın yapamadığı kadar
başarılı bir şekilde derilerinin rengini
ve desenini değiştirip kendilerini
kamufle edebiliyorlar
abone ol
bu ben yıllardır laboratuvarda bu
hayvanlarla çalışıyorum onlara demin
gördüğünüz satranç tahtasından sinüs
dalgasına kadar doğal olmayan ama
istatistiklerini bildiğin fonlar
sunuyorum ve of onların önünde hangi
kamuflaj üniformasını giyeceklerini
tahmin etmeye çalışıyorum ve inanın ki
bana bu hayvanların en etkileyici yanı o
giyecekleri üniformayı bir kaç mili
saniye içinde girebilmeleri değil renk
körü olarak seçip diyebilmeli ve onların
renk körlüğü önül ışığın denizin
içindeki ışınsu renkleri yok etmesinden
kaynaklanıyor tamamen gözlerinde renk
görecek bir donanım olmamasından
kaynaklanıyor
ben size laboratuvarda bir gösterdiğim
örnekler tabii ki on santim su içinde
doğal şartları temsil etmeyen örnekler
bu hayvanların doğal ortamındaki görsel
öğeler çok daha karmaşık o yüzden de
sizi gittiğim yerler içerisinde beni en
çok heyecanlandıran bana en çok ilham
veren dünyanın en güzel köşelerinden
birine götürmek istiyorum bir örnek
göstermek için izmir'e izmir körfezinde
çektiğim bu fotoğrafta kendisini kamufle
etmiş bir tane mürekkep oluvermek kapalı
içinden beyaz kemik çıkan kuş kafesleri
ne konu görmüşsünüzdür buradaki mürekkep
balığını görebildik mi
o biraz zor burada
var burada bir tane var buradaki
görebildik mi
ve o da aslında burada şimdi bu
resimleri de gördünüz sorunu zorluğuna
bakın suyun içinde renkler var ama suyun
içindeki ışık renkleri yok ediyor
denizin içinde renk göremeyen hayvanlar
var ama göremedikleri o renkleri
birilerinde sentezlenip o renge öbürüne
biliyorlar
bu peki bunu nasıl yapıyorlar
bu şaşıracaksınız
ve hiçbir fikrimiz yok yok bilmiyoruz
bağlayabilir ben de bilmiyorum ama
bildiğim tek bir şey var o da bizim izi
bağlayıp mars'taki ahtapotlara gitmeden
önce yerli ve milli ahtapot lardan daha
öğreneceğimiz çok şey var teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]